to be small enough and safe enough uh
for us to land in safely and fly there
after we've just after we've gotten rid
of the parachute
and we also have a social media question
coming in sansacari14
on instagram is asking how does the sky
crane decide
where to move itself after the payload
lands
after the payload lands after the rover
touches down uh the
the sky crane the descent stage which is
that rocket powered jet pack above it
the first job of course is to make sure
you don't hurt the rover so it'll turn
forward or backward so that the engine
plumes don't pass over the rover
so it'll come up and start to turn and
it'll go in whichever direction is
closest
to north so it can either go forward if
that's the way north is or go toward the
rear of the rover
if that's where north is and it'll fly
about a third of a mile or so away
thanks for talking to us today al thank
you very much
now let's head back to mission control
for an update from swati
raquel so remember that command that we
sent
at around 11 35 to turn the transmitter
off
we are just about to get confirmation
that perseverance has received the
command the command took 11 minutes to
go to perseverance
and then the reply took 11 minutes back
from perseverance to the ground so we
should hear
any second now that we have officially
turned off the transmitter and after
that we will be about
four minutes from the start of entry
descent and landing mode at this point
we will transition
from the cruise approach mode to entry
descent and landing
and that means our travel from earth to
mars is done
and now we just need to get to the
surface
so far things are looking good great
we'll come back
lady zoe our attractive stations have
all confirmed the results of the
transmitter drive off
and in lock one way copy ace
pdf flight flight gts
at this time i'd like to disable the
alarms before edl main
so please disable all the alarm files
and start a new
downlink session we'll talk about vp
copy that proceeding now
you find confirmation that we are now
officially one way
and the transmitter is off
rover mission has helped shape the other
started the landing of the pathfinder
more than 20
years ago leading up to where we are
today with perseverance
perseverance deputy project manager
jennifer trosper
has worked on every mars rover mission
and she joins us now
jennifer how does perseverance fit into
the history
of exploring mars thanks raquel it's
great to be here
well perseverance is nasa's fifth rover
on mars and i've had the privilege of
working on
every one of them and the very first
rover was the sojourner rover we sent in
1997 and it was the size of a microwave
oven and even at that small size
sojourner was able to transform the way
that we explore mars from stationary
landers
to small roving robots that go from
place to place just like a geologist
would
on earth so once we had that roving
capability
then we sent our twin rovers spirit and
opportunity
spirit and opportunity were tasked with
finding evidence of ancient water on
mars
now they did they're great explorers and
both of them found
ample evidence that water had once
existed on the surface of mars
but we had a question another question
then was
mars ever habitable if water had been
there and that's when we sent
curiosity now curiosity was a major
upgrade
to our rover fleet she's the size of a
small car
she uh landed with the sky crane system
instead of airbags
and she also carries along her own
sample analytics lab
and she's still operating today and
during her exploration she has found
evidence of a habitable
environment in an ancient lake bed on
mars
so now we're sending perseverance
perseverance is tasked
with answering the question and looking
for evidence
of ancient microbial life on mars
be the smartest and most capable rover
we've ever sent
speaking of perseverance can you tell us
more about how perseverance
is smarter than its predecessors yes
we've made
a lot of upgrades to help her along with
the surface mission
one of them is for her autonomous
traverse capability
when i say autonomous traverse i mean we
tell her where we want her to end up
and she has to figure out the safe and
best way to get there in order to do
that she uses her cameras
algorithms a computer so we've given her
another computer we've upgraded the
cameras and we've upgraded the
algorithms
now she drives three times as fast as
curiosity could drive
in this autonomous traverse mode in fact
her
average daily distance for driving about
200 meters is close to the maximum
distance
any rover has ever driven in a day on
mars so she's fast
another thing that we've done which is
the most significant upgrade
that we've made is the sample caching
system itself
curiosity has a robotic arm like
perseverance has a robotic arm but on
the end of perseverance's robotic arm
is a coring drill that will go and take
rock cores
transfer them into sample tubes and into
the rover where another robotic arm
will take those tubes will seal them and
store them and eventually
drop them on the surface of mars for
future return to earth
great and we also have a social media
question about perseverance
erica a s on instagram wants to know
what the wheels of the rover are made
out of
great question well you may think we
make them out of some
material you've never heard of it turns
out they're made of aluminum
now perseverance's wheels are a little
thicker than curiosities but they're
actually both made out of aluminum
and one more question for you can you
tell us more about the importance of
where you are
right now in the building yes i am
above on the second floor above the
cruise mission support area that you've
been watching
and this is the surface mission support
area so as soon as perseverance lands
all commands all this this room will
take over become headquarters
for operating perseverance on mars
thanks for taking the time to talk to us
today jennifer
thank you now we now know perseverance's
place in history
let's take an up-close look at the rover
with mars 2020 system testbed engineer
elio morillo thank you raquel
i'm standing in front of the mars 2020
perseverance
scaled model as you can tell this
vehicle
is about the size of a mini cooper these
wheels are obviously
black here and they look like rubber but
they're actually fully made of metal
these wheels are designed to allow us to
climb over obstacles and of course climb
over hills
and minimize the amount of slipping once
we're traversing on the surface of mars
here in the front of the rover we have
the sample caching system and of course
at the very front end of this is the
robotic arm which this entire system is
arguably the most complex robotic system
we've ever sent
outside of earth here at the tip of the
arm we have a turret which contains
a suite of instruments along with some
drills and core capabilities
that will allow us to do contact science
once we get to the surface of mars
not only that this robotic system is
equipped to collect
samples about the size of a piece of
chalk that then eventually will be
stored
inside of the vehicle and dropped off in
a later location
so that an eventual mission can go and
return these samples to earth
something we've never done in the past
here in the front we have the remote
sensing
mast something of note is that this
mechanism is going to be stowed upon the
touchdown on the surface of mars and one
of the first critical activities we do
is deploy this mechanism
this mechanism includes several cameras
that are going to give us some of the
most breathtaking images we've ever
taken on mars
along with that we have some lasers as
well as a spectrometer they're going to
allow us to do some remote science
here you see some of these extrusions
that are part of the larger weather
suite of instruments
that will allow us to characterize the
local climate around
perseverance so that's a quick tour of
the rover but i gotta get back to work
so back to you
[Music]
perseverance is collecting samples of
martian rock for future return to
earth we've heard that scientists have
been wanting to bring
martian samples back for many
generations
and here to talk a little bit about that
is nasa's planetary science division
director lori glaze
who joins us now to talk about the role
perseverance
will play in nasa's future goals welcome
lori
hi now as you just heard we've heard
that scientists have been wanting to
bring back these martian samples for a
very long time
why do we need to bring them back that's
really a great great question
you know we actually have examples of
mars already here on earth that came
here as
meteorites but we don't know exactly
where they came from on mars and then
they also have had to make the trip from
mars to earth and so they
got altered during that time and then
during their entry and descent into the
earth's atmosphere that also changes
what those those rocks are like
so being able to go to mars and actually
collect a sample where we know exactly
where it came from
and we know we can preserve it and keep
it pristine
and carry it all the way back here this
will be incredibly important to help us
answer
questions about uh the geologic history
of mars
understanding how it formed and evolved
and also
really important questions about whether
or not life
actually existed on mars three and a
half billion years ago and whether that
life if it existed has been preserved
in the surface of mars now lori these
sample tubes that perseverance is going
to be
collecting they're the cleanest things
ever created on earth tell me a little
bit about that
oh my goodness we worked so hard
the team here at jpl is absolutely
incredible to
assure that those sample tubes are
incredibly clean
one of the main goals of this mission is
to
be able to detect if there's actual life
that's preserved
um ancient life preserved in those rocks
in those samples
and we definitely don't want to be
carrying you know our own dna
off to mars and then bring it back here
to confuse our scientists when they're
trying to study those samples
so it it is an incredibly clean uh set
of
equipment that's been sent there as you
said the cleanest thing we've ever sent
into space
now this is a very complicated campaign
can you break down for us how it's going
to work
and if there's any international
partners working with us
you are correct the the marsh sample
return campaign
is incredibly complex in fact it's
probably the most challenging thing
we've ever tried to do
but we're definitely not going to try
and do it alone we have
great partners with the european space
agency
and the way this campaign is going to
work well perseverance is the first step
chapter one is going to mars and
collecting the samples chapter two
is going to be a sample return lander
that we hope to launch in around 26 to
28 2026 to 2028
and that lander uh it'll be an american
lander carrying
a fetch rover that's provided by
european space agency
and that little fetch rover will drive
out and pick up the samples that
perseverance left on the surface of mars
and the fetch river will bring them back
and load them into a rocket that we call
the mars ascent vehicle which will be
the first ever launch from another
planet
and it will launch those samples into
orbit around mars
in the meantime european space agency
will have an orbiter
that's in orbit around mars that can
rendezvous and
capture those samples and then bring
them back to earth for
for us to study back here in our amazing
laboratories
a lot of firsts it sounds like lori and
another first how is perseverance and
the mars sample return mission
going to help the future exploration
human exploration of mars
i'm so glad you asked that i think we're
going to get a lot
of great information from our sample
return
with again being able to land the
heaviest payload we've ever landed on
mars will be that sample return lander
that's critical
to us learning how to land humans on
mars and then we are definitely going to
want to be able to launch the humans
back off of mars so that mars ascent
vehicle is going to be
critical that that first step of the
first launch from another planet
so exciting laurie and speaking about
the mars generation
we're now going to take a student
question for you from
livia hi my name is olivia and my
question
is what made you want to study mars and
why are you working so hard
and willing um to wait so long for a
sample thank you
olivia that is such a great question um
and and i enjoy mars
just because it can tell us so much
about how our solar system formed and
evolved
um all of the planets can tell us
different parts of that story and mars
is a really key piece of that
and one of the main reasons we're
willing to wait so long to get the
sample back
is that we've got great scientists that
are all about your age and in about
10 or 15 or 20 years you'll be the
generation that's going to actually get
to work with these samples when
when they come back you'll be the
scientists and engineers that will
will be the the next generation to to
change how we think about
about mars and how we think about life
in the solar system
that was a great question lori reach for
the stars
future little scientists and engineers
thank you so much for joining us here
today lori it's my pleasure thanks
back to you raquel for another mission
update thanks marina
the cruise team for perseverance
controls the rover on its way to mars
and moments ago they handed it over to
the landing team
and it looks like team leaders in
mission control are about to talk to
both
teams so let's listen in uh the cbm
change as i mentioned previously is to
the edl reserve two-way non-coherent
activity copy flight
edl face go ahead okay
pep talk i guess to the team all right
uh you know i'm terrible pep talks i
think you
my reputation precedes me there and uh
look i know this hasn't been easy right
i'm not even sure we've even been all in
the same room at the same time i mean
i'm staring at folks across the
uh across the internet as well even now
right only
yeah voice check okay
i do want to just extend uh my heartfelt
appreciation from the edl team
to the uh to the launch cruise team uh
you've done everything we've asked for
right i mean you've battled anomalies
you've you know dealt with jesse's
you've done everything
uh he delivered a healthy spacecraft to
the place that we want to go i mean
she's right on target right
we did the last maneuver literally two
months ago right this is pretty
incredible
in my opinion um and she's on with the
right information to help us land you
know doing the parameter update last
night we're ready to roll you've done
everything right
and you put up with us too right you put
up with our eccentricities and
the things we like to do in edl land so
i very much appreciate that
so you all should sleep in on friday
since uh
i you know you guys have earned it um
thanks for literally and figuratively
putting us in the right position to
succeed
and uh let's land on mars together
copy edl phase and as flight director i
also would like to thank the whole team
crewsops edl ops
edl team and the surface ops as well
it's been an amazing journey i think we
all know that and
it's been my honor and pleasure to work
with you all side by side
and your tireless efforts and endurance
in the face
of our challenges has been truly truly
inspiring
so kudos to you mission would you like
to see something
yeah just echoing the same words that
that al and magdy have uh
have mentioned you guys have overcome
great obstacles in the last six and a
half months and it
started with an earthquake in this room
on launch day
at l minus 20 minutes so i can't be more
proud than all of the achievements that
you guys have
have pulled off in the last six and a
half months
whatever happens in the next hour and a
half you can be proud of the
achievements that you've
accomplished so far i look forward to
seeing you on the other side
and i only wish that the rest of our
team could be sharing this moment with
us
uh this is a very unusual event this
room is only as half as full
as it would be if we weren't in this
pandemic so
missing everybody on the team who's not
with us here today
and go edl
welcome to the eeo family
and with that godspeed perseverance
all right activity go ahead and continue
the report
sure being fight um we've since
completed the edl start anchor
um as i was mentioning we changed our
cbm row to edl reserve two-way
non-coherent
that row reinforces our cbm windows
disabled
keeps our packetization on it turns off
our ranging and switches to the
auxiliary
oscillator we've also started our
real-time data products
and reinforced medley on
at this time now we just heard
perseverance team leaders thank the
cruise team
for their work in guiding the rover to
mars
now did you know the rover name and mars
helicopter name
came from students well a couple weeks
ago marina was able to catch up with
them
thanks raquel earlier this year nasa and
our partners held a nationwide essay
contest to name
our mars rover alex mather a seventh
grader from springfield virginia
submitted the winning essay that was
selected by nasa from a field of more
than
28 000 entries from k through 12
students in
every state in the u.s vanessa roupani's
essay for ingenuity
was so compelling nasa thought it would
be a perfect name for the history making
helicopter
a technology demonstration carried
aboard the perseverance rover
alex and vanessa join us now welcome you
guys
hello space nerds hi
now you got to go to florida and watch
the launch live
back in july alex what were you feeling
as you saw that rocket launch into the
sky
i read a lot of books written by
astronauts and
every single one of them always talks
about
the raw power behind the space launch
and i definitely feel like watching the
launch invoke to that sense
of of well inspiration
mixed with anticipation along with that
rumble in my chest
that's very inspirational and i'm sure
that you have had many conversations
with your classmates since this all
began
what kind of questions have they asked
you i got some people
asking me about what this helicopter is
what this rover is what are they
actually going to do
so i love that this whole experience
sparked a greater interest in the
mission in my community
why do you think it's so important for
kids to be inspired by space exploration
because space is the future and kids are
the future
learning about space and watching the
story of
humanity spread to the stars happen is
watching the future
happen and seeing history unfold
the best way to keep our home safe and
protect our planet is to learn from the
worlds around it
so i think it's really important for the
next generation of scientists to be
engaged in that type of exploration to
make our home the best place it can be
now speaking of the future what has your
life been like since
naming the rover and helicopter has it
sparked any future aspirations for the
two of you
oh man i am currently applying to a
science and technology school for high
school
i'm hoping for a nasa internship
sometime along the way
with my ultimate goal being to join the
incredible team of scientists and
engineers
who are about to make this happen this
whole experience has definitely shown me
that i want to go into the space
industry
i came home from florida i did all my
college applications and checked
aerospace engineering on all the boxes
i mean the whole time we were there i
was thinking why would anyone want to do
anything else
so true and the best of luck to both of
you
thank you so much for joining us here
today alex and vanessa
thank you for having us thank you so
much i had a great time
now your essays as well as the top 155
finalist essays are riding on the
perseverance rover
along with nearly 11 million of the
names from
all over the world that were submitted
before launch
if you miss the chance to get your name
on perseverance
then you will get another chance to
reserve a spot on the next mission to
mars
so make sure that you sign up now at
mars.nasa.gov
for your boarding pass
as virtual celebrations are happening
all over the globe
let's take a look at some of your
submissions on our social channels
showing us how you're celebrating the
perseverance landing
right now and remember to hashtag
count down to mars and send those in we
would love to show them off
look at these kids they are getting so
excited everyone's watching it
a lot of classrooms are watching it oh
and great someone
did a lego version of perseverance which
is
awesome it looks fantastic we love
getting all your pictures out there
we've gotten a lot of artwork from kids
which has been great i know i have a
nine-year-old john at home and he loves
to draw the rover
and look at that that is awesome that's
better than anything i could bake that's
for sure
perseverance in a cake that looks so
great delicious
i want to get into that
another great send-in from david bowie
reel
thank you so much for your submissions
remember hashtag countdown to mars we
love to see how you're celebrating
now you might know our next guest from
shows like emily's wonderlab
joining me now is emily kellendrelli
thank you
so much for being here with us today
hi thanks so much for having me now you
are very passionate about getting kids
interested in science and space
exploration
why do you think kids are so excited
about space
well i know the reason i'm excited about
space and i think it's the same reason
that many others are excited about space
and it's that
the people in the space industry work to
answer two
of the biggest questions that humans
have ever asked
are we alone in the universe and where
did we all
come from and by sending a rover to mars
we are gaining
evidence for the answers to these
questions more evidence than we ever had
before and i think that's so exciting
it is and i know you get loads of
interesting questions from kids have you
gotten any
about mars specifically oh my gosh yes
everybody loves smarts it's in movies
and books and tv shows and everybody
loves smart so one of the things that i
get asked a lot
is that you know it's called the red
planet why is it red
well it's red because it's literally
rusty the top layer of soil on
mars has iron oxide in it or rust and
rust has that brownish red color so
it's it's red because it's rusty and
also because it's red they ask
is it red hot is it really hot on mars
and well
no actually it's colder than the earth
it's farther away from the sun so as you
would imagine it's a little bit colder
than the earth
it also has a really thin atmosphere so
the heat that it does have it has a hard
time keeping in
um and so it's a little bit colder but
then i also get asked
what would i weigh on mars that's a
really fun question
so on mars it's a little bit smaller
than the earth so the gravity there is
weaker it's about 3 8 the gravity that
we have here on earth
so if you weighed 100 pounds here on
earth you weigh 38 pounds on mars or 100
kilograms here on earth
38 kilograms on mars
those are all super fun i think even
some adults want to know the answers to
those questions emily
now why do you think it's so important
to educate kids about science and
give them that great foundation well
science is the language of nature and
learning about science and learning how
to
think like a scientist means you are
learning how to systematically
seek out the world you are learning the
scientific method you're learning how to
be a critical thinker
and honestly those skills are great for
whatever you end up wanting
true if you want to be a scientist or an
opera singer that holds true what are
you most excited about today
i mean humans are launching a robot
to mars that doesn't happen every day i
think in all of the hecticness that is
going on today and all of the nerves
i just everyone can take a moment to sit
back and remember that
we live in a time when humans have the
ability to send a robot to another
planet
and that is just that's so cool to me
it is very cool emily take a deep breath
thanks for joining us here
thanks for having me sending it back to
you now raquel
thanks marina we are offering lots of
ways to ride along with us to mars
now put yourself right into the action
now with our perseverance photo booth
you can pose next to the rover place
yourself in our mission control
and even see what you might look like
taking a selfie on the red planet
there you'll also have a chance to sign
up to send your name to mars on nasa's
next flight to the red planet it's all
available at
go.nasa.gov mars
2020 toolkit and joining us now
is jpl chief engineer and landing
veteran rob
manning he will be breaking down key
moments coming up
and very few people know more about
landing on mars than rob
going back to the pathfinder mission in
1997.
thanks for joining us today rob yeah
thank you very much for comfort
for having me here and what a wonderful
experience
what a wonderful day for a beautiful day
in california
we're just so excited here anxious
worried but
very hopeful rob i have a question for
you there is a landing tradition at jpl
that
involves eating peanuts for good luck uh
can you tell us how did that start
yes it started in the mid 1960s what
happened was
he had a series of missions that had
failures the ranger program
in the early 1960s one after another
failed and what happened was one day a
fellow by their dick wallace on their
on ranger number seven on the seventh
attempt
decided to bring peanuts to the ops area
just before the
before the launch and guess what that
mission worked now we're not supposed to
be too super superstitious we're
engineers and scientists after all
but we love tradition and ever since
then before launch and before critical
events like entry descent landing we
have brought out peanuts and shared them
with the team
and it's been really a wonderful little
experience and and so
this is something we will do we're doing
right now and uh
and it's something that we just can't
help ourselves it's just part of the
experience
well speaking of the experience how did
the perseverance team keep the tradition
alive this year
well this year we're passed out little
package of penis to the team
and they can sneak a pen one peanut in
their mouth for uh
as part of to keep the tradition alive
but you know this is part of the covet
experience but we can't leave this one
uh undone so this is what we're doing
and we're and uh
and this is gonna help us land safely
all right
thanks rob i have some questions for you
a little later on but we are heading
back to swati mohan who
is part of the landing team she'll be
calling out key milestone and events as
they happen
from mission control so let's listen in
right now
so right now we're still about 20
minutes from entry and
the el phase is giving a last minute
confirmation of what will be happening
in the upcoming changes to the vehicle
just to remind the team
and this will allow us to steer our
trajectory
as we make our way through the
atmosphere
and this is one of the things that
allowed
msl the curiosity rover to
land where it did and we're depending on
the same
type of entry guidance this time around
to help get us very close to our target
as we make our way uh through entry
finish the
uh finish our guided entry profile
we'll do a maneuver called heading
alignment where we
point to the target and get ready to
deploy the parachute but before we
deploy the parachute
we need to get rid of a set of balance
passes that have been giving us
a center of gravity or cg offset
throughout the guided entry phase so
these are called
the uh the enter balance masses we also
call this maneuver um suffer sufr
or straighten up and fly right so we'll
go ahead and eject
those masses when we get
a trigger from the gnc system telling us
that we're at the appropriate
range to the target to do so as soon as
we deploy those
we will no longer have a cd offset
and will be ready to deploy the
parachute 17 seconds later
right where the perseverance team is
sitting now what's in store for them
as we approach landing i'm going to hold
here
for uh pdf prep as we're about to start
that anchor
copy piece two an activity please call
that out when
announcement
all right now rob uh you've been right
where the perseverance team is sitting
now
uh what's in store for them as we
approach
landing well this is the really
this is the nail biting time um
fortunately we still have ones and zeros
coming but very soon as we approach true
stage separation
the the transmitter on this rover that's
been we've been using all the way to get
to mars is going to be turned off
so we're but and and we will lose our
ability to see ones as heroes but the
good thing is once the cruise stage is
gone there's another radio
that will continue transmitting uh a
tone
so that like a flashlight that will
allow us to see at least see that the
vehicle is still
on and that and that color of that
flashlight tells us a little bit with
what state
this the rover's in but soon after that
um it won't be very long before
we'll be able to hear more ones and
zeros coming from the spacecraft
um so this is a really exciting time and
and it's just important to remind people
this is a
uh there's a lot that can go wrong in a
date like today there are thousands of
things that have to go right
yeah we had success in the past landing
on mars
you think it gets easier but it really
doesn't why is it still so difficult
well it's well because it's involved
thousands and thousands of things
hundreds of thousands of lines of code
there there is uh there's 79 pyrotechnic
devices
each have to work perfectly one critical
wire short or one
key thing mechanism that doesn't work or
breaks and it's mission over
and so it's you know and and so and it's
very easy we're human beings we're not
perfect
mistakes can be made um we each count on
each other
to to find uh our own mistakes and we
and we
work very hard to to learn from the
mistakes of the past
we've had many failures half remind
people roughly half little
around half of the missions to mars over
history have failed
um and so it's it's it's that could
happen today too even though we've had a
nice wonderful
string of successes in the united states
it's still
a a still a bit of a gamble a gamble
that we've we have hoped that we have
we have aired in the side of luck and
and and we've stacked the
dice that stacked the deck and uh loaded
the dice to make this thing
succeed but um if we do if we do fail
if something bad happens today i can
tell you we're going to learn it we'll
have the data to tell us what happened
we'll know why we'll figure it out
and and if we are allowed we will pick
ourselves up
and get us back on the horse and if
congress and nasa allow we will try
again
as we always do we will learn from our
mistakes and
what are the possible scenarios we could
be looking at today
well there's things things like uh one
of the key
stressful elements for all of us is
parachute inflation
but just even separating from the
pre-stage is a pretty major event lots
of devices have to work properly
um certainly on the heat shield
separation uh getting getting the the
descent engine started there's no less
than than uh uh
16 rocket motors that have to work one
eight to control during entry another
eight to control it during landing
i i said it's a lot of stuff and it all
has to work and guess what
we haven't done this before with this
vehicle ever this is this first attempt
to actually land
we can't try this on earth we can't do
uh we don't have test pilots and try it
out on this planet before the big show
so this vehicle is doing it for the
first time we've done the best testing
we can do in bits and pieces
but you know it's it's as best as we
could do and and uh
but i think our team is up to it we've
this team is the best it's a diverse
intelligent amazing group of people of
people from all over the world who
worked on this
not just here in california but all over
nasa contributors
from aerospace universities countries
around the world
it is just an incredible remarkable
engineering achievement
and i am just so proud of this team
thanks rob now let's listen back into
mission control
right you're about 14 minutes from entry
interface
the vehicle is currently preparing
the heat rejection system that has kept
the thermal system cool inside the
aeroshell for about the last six months
this will allow the fifth cup to more
easily cut the line
in upcoming cruise stage separation
which is under
four minutes now
we have now enabled the rover pyrobus
the pyrotechnic uh system um that that
was powering off the cruise stage
devices
and these are the these are the things
in the cruise stage that will that we no
longer need
with the pyrotechnic system working we
can you can we can
explode devices the vehicle is preparing
for the upcoming cruise stage duration
in about 3 minutes 15 seconds
by powering off all the devices on the
cruise stage in order to
take me safe once the crew stage is
jettisoned
yeah this is a this is a this cruise
stage has been very reliable
we are firing our first pyros to vent
the hrs liquid and gas
this has been the coolant that's kept
their vehicle from getting too hot in
the way of mars
we have to vent it into space
and so this is one of the first uh major
events that take place as part of entry
descent landing
the traffic maker is complete we will
see the next anchor in approximately
three minutes
okay we are currently 12 and a half
minutes from entry interface
we are coming up on cruise stage
separation in two minutes and 20 seconds
what's happening now rob okay well j
we're just waiting the the
rover is completely in charge it's doing
all the things we've taught it how to do
it's all built into the software we've
tested it
over and over and over again this team
has spent
24 hours a day seven days a week testing
this thing
for years and and so this is uh this is
really the culmination of
all that work so this vehicle is is
going to is getting ready
to push that cruise stage away uh once
it gets pushed away um it
it the entry system with the rover
inside with the rover is still in charge
it's going to get ready to take the
vehicle turn it to the right orientation
and aim it to mars and and
prepare for entering the atmosphere
this won't be long um be prepared for
this event
about a minute and a half from the stage
separation
uh 11 minutes 20 seconds from entry
interface
okay so it's about 10 minutes from
cruising separation until
entering the top of the atmosphere from
then on and out things happen
to the mfsk tomes telemetry will have
stopped
telecom is confirming that the
spacecraft has switched to broadcasting
tones these tones are received directly
from perseverance but
have very limited information content we
won't receive
real-time information until about
nine ten minutes from now once the mars
reconnaissance orbiter
starts relaying information from
perseverance we are under a minute from
cruise stage separation
about 10 and a half minutes from entry
interface
it's getting exciting i have to admit i
am quite anxious
uh but very hopeful this machine is
going to do we have so you're seeing the
heartbeat tones
okay that means that we there's no more
ones and zeros coming it's just the
vehicle telling us it's still alive
we're continuing to receive tones from
perseverance coming
standing by for cruise stage separation
we have indication that cruise stage
separation has been confirmed by the
spacecraft
we're off on a good start in about one
minute press advances landing software
will wake up
and begin the final preparations for
entry the first action it will
do is to fire warm-up pulses with the
entry thrusters
these pulses ensure that the spacecraft
gets the thrust that it wants during
entry interface
we're about nine minutes from entry
interface
okay so now the vehicle's on its own
it's turning itself into the direction
of
facing the heat shield toward mars and
uh
and we'll eventually uh uh hitting the
top of the atmosphere we're not far away
this is going to go very quickly from
here on out
that's confirmation that we got shadowed
by the cruise stage
as it passed through our beam to the
earth
telecom indicated actually that we could
see a signal that the crew stage went
between
the perseverance engine capsule and
earth so we saw a little blip
uh the data stream indicating the
crusade separation
we have confirmation that the vehicle
has started warming up those entry
thrusters
what pulses have begun
at this point the spacecraft is trying
to stop
its spin from the cruise two revolutions
per minute down to zero
and then we'll turn to its desired
orientation from
entry it will separate the two balance
maps that has kept it balanced during
all of cruz
this will allow the entry capsule to
have lift when
it enters the atmosphere the competition
that they've kept has turned
to the desire entry attitude
we're about seven and a half minutes
from entry interface
okay the vehicle is pointed in the right
direction
thrusters are warmed up and doing their
job
and now we've spun down from
two revolutions per minute that the
vehicle had the whole way to on the way
to mars it's a spin stabilized
spacecraft
and then from here on out it's going to
just be a bullet
and it's going to control its orient
orientation and attitude
via rockets on the back of the power
points carrier lock
password the dte from
radio science from uh green bank reports
carried a lot
did you see the carrier on the downlink
flight level one we are continuing to
wait
for entry interface for about six
minutes and 45 seconds from entry
interface
we have confirmation from greenback that
they are receiving
direct earth telemetry via that
path the spacecraft performance is
currently
transmitting heartbeat tones these tones
indicate that
perseverance is operating normally and
has nothing significant to report
this is as expected we're currently just
over six minutes from entry interface
okay and now we wait
as soon as we get to the top of the
atmosphere the atm will be very quickly
which is the entry point
it won't be very long before the the
atmosphere will start
getting thicker and thicker it's going
very quickly at a fairly steep angle of
15 degrees
into the atmosphere as it starts to slow
down just under
uh about five and a half minutes from
entry interface
we're still receiving heartbeat tones we
expect to continue receiving heartbeat
tones until about five minutes
after entry at that time perseverance
will be
no longer in view of our antennas here
on earth
about 90 seconds prior to entry the mars
reconnaissance orbiter
should begin receiving telemetry from
perseverance
and streaming at checkers in near real
time
there are a few expected short outages
such as when we have a plasma backed out
or when we enter the peak heating
phase aside from these outages caused by
the plasma blackout
antenna switching or high dynamic events
spacecraft events
we should have telemetry until about 90
seconds
after landing a positive blackout
is when the signal from perseverance
isn't strong enough to make it through
the superheated super fast
air flowing around the spacecraft all
the way down to earth once the
temperature drops below that peak
heating we do reacquire the signal from
perseverance
we are currently about four and a half
minutes from entry intervase
perseverance continues to report
heartbeat tones indicating everything
is nominal okay
what we're looking for now is where mars
reconstance orbiter should be in view
soon of our vehicle and be able to
listen to ones and zeros coming from a
separate radio
that's really designed to talk between
spacecraft camera reports the electro
radio is powered on ready to receive
signals from the lander
okay mro is ready and less enabled
and waiting further to hear from our
rover constantly orbiter has reported
that it's
ready to receive the signals from
perseverance it should be in
a few minutes here we're just flight
local one
from entry interface
we don't need these ones and zeros as
swati said
but to land safely but we really need it
for our own
uh health and well-being today to keep
our nerves in
control around this time a second
spacecraft may then
should begin picking up telemetry from
perseverance and will continue to record
that telemetry until several minutes
post landing
we won't get that data for several hours
after landing
as it's being recorded and then will be
forwarded to earth
later we are continuing to receive
heartbeat tones
indicating that everything is nominal
we're currently at
about three minutes until entry
interface
okay
very soon we'll be getting ones and
zeros i hope
my radio on the rover
the interface is nothing more than just
an arbitrary place in the sky that we've
defined to be above the atmosphere
but but from that point on uh there's
definitely
uh atmosphere and above it there isn't
there are two
minutes from entry interface it
will transmit heartbeat tones indicating
everything
is normal
so the tones can tell us whether
something is bad or not is happening so
so far the heartbeat is doing well
so the vehicle thinks it's up it's in
good shape to land
which is a great sign
we're just under two minutes from entry
interface as it gets closer to mars
presidents is actually being pulled in
by gravity and accelerating
by the time price range reaches entry
interface point
he should be going just under 5.4
kilometers per second
we had about 90 seconds from entry
interface
and standing by for mars reconnaissance
orbiter to pick up the telemetry
we are one minute from entry interface
mro's are in receive mode
we have confirmation that the
multi-constant orbiter is
now relaying data from perseverance
we're about 30 seconds from entry
interface
procurement is going about 5.2
kilometers per second
and is about 190 kilometers altitude
above the surface of mars
and from here just data flow
seconds from entry interface
5.3 kilometers per second and an
altitude
150 numbers from the surface mars
we have confirmation of entry interface
presidents is currently going 5.3
kilometers per second
at an altitude of about 120 kilometers
from the surface of mars
the fish is now waiting until it begins
feeling the atmosphere slow it down
once there is enough atmosphere it will
start controlling its
path to the landing target
navigation is also confirming that we
can see a little bit of that slowdown
of the atmosphere on
the perseverance entry capsule
current velocity is about 5.36
kilometers per second and an altitude of
about 67
kilometers from the surface we are
probably seeing mro plasma blackout at
this point
the vehicle should be doing its turns
right now hammer has lost lock
president
we have indications that perseverance is
now
performing bank reversals in the
atmosphere
these are the steps in order to control
its distance to the landing target
first events has just passed through the
point of maximum deceleration
and has indicated that it felt
approximately
10 earth gs of deceleration
camera is lock again
yes yes yes we saw a small outage
uh of the uhf telemetry from mars
requirements orbiter
during that peak heating phase likely
caused
by the plasma blackout perseverance is
still continuing to perform bank
reversals
in the atmosphere to control its
distance to the landing target
perseverance is going about one
kilometer per second
at an altitude of about 16 kilometers
from the surface of mars
we have entered heading alignment which
means
perseverance is no longer trying to
control the distance to mars but
in to the target on mars but instead is
flying
straight to the target
periscope
our current velocity is about five
hundred
and meters per second and an altitude of
about 15 kilometers
from the surface
cameras reporting good telemetry lock
we are coming upon the straighten up we
are starting the straighten up and fly
right maneuver
where the spacecraft will jettison the
entry balance masses
in preparation for parachute deploy and
to roll over to give the radar a better
look at the ground
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and we are seeing
significant deceleration
in velocity our current velocity is 450
meters per second
at an altitude of about 12 kilometers
from the surface of mars
first advance is now slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated
this allows both the radar and the
cameras to get their first look at the
surface
current velocity is 145 meters per
second and an altitude of about
10 km nine and a half kilometers above
the surface
yes yes yes first rinse
now has radar lock on the ground current
velocity is about 100 meters per second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
[Applause]
press advance is continuing to descend
on the parachute
we are coming up on the initialization
of terrain relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity is
about 90 meters per second at an
altitude of 4.2 kilometers
we have confirmation that the lander
vision system has produced a valid
solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
we have timing of the landing engines
current velocity is 83 meters per second
at about 2.6 kilometers from the surface
mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated
we are currently performing the divert
maneuver current velocity is about 75
meters per second at an
altitude of about a kilometer off the
surface of mars
you're on safety bravo we have
completed our terrain relative
navigation current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude of about
300 meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means
we are conducting the sky crane about to
conduct the 5 plane maneuver
we've lost direct earth tones
as expected as expected sky crew
maneuver has started
about 20 meters off the surface
we're getting signals from mro
uhf is good
touchdown confirmed
that's one way to save shift search the
first event
is continuing to transmit direct
through mazda kind of orbiter to
[Music]
reports they're still getting telemetry
from the lander all right
all right all stations wow we got it
we're gonna wait for the images wow this
is so exciting
the team is beside themselves it's so
surreal
stay tuned we might get some pictures
so much has been riding on this
yeah yeah we just heard the news that
perseverance is alive on the surface of
mars
it's not uh
we have seen the completion of edl 3000
copy activity that is as
amarillo is expected seeing a strong
signal from the lander
we have just heard the news that
perseverance is alive
on the surface of mars congratulations
to the mission
and looks like we have some more news in
it looks like we're getting the first
image here take a look at the first
image
flight this is ol3 i have
the target point on the map when you are
ready
we are ready l3 go for it
wow
[Applause]
flight i'll be uh moving in showing you
the safe zone that we've landed in
[Applause]
team has just put the first image firm
perseverance on the surface of mars
now it comes from the engineering
cameras known as the hazard camera
this camera is mainly used to help the
rover drive safely around mars
and we will get higher resolution photos
later in the day
stand by for steve yeah
[Music]
you did you led the team you made it
we just got our second image in our
second image
is in okay these
these we have a camera in the front and
out rear the the spacecraft
uh it's uh it's it's they're near the
ground so these are pretty close you can
see the wheels there
uh and and and they're a little dirty
because you've got
glass covers over these these cameras
but we took these
seconds after landing so so there's
still dust in the air from our landing
event
uh so this is this is happening um uh
you know this happened just seconds ago
just arrived
and this is really amazing
and uh we even know where we landed this
is the most amazing thing the vehicle
has told us where
where it's landed because figured it out
you know this is a sign
nasa works nasa works and we put our
arms together
and our hands together and our brains
together we can succeed
this is what nasa does this is what we
can do as a country
on all of the problems we we have we
need to work together
to do these kinds of things and make
success happen
joining us now is the acting
administrator of nasa steve
jurisic steve welcome and
congratulations
hey thank you what an amazing day
how does it feel to have another rover
on mars
uh it's amazing um to have perseverance
join curiosity on mars and
what what a just a credit to the team i
mean just what an
amazing team um to work through
all the adversity um that goes and all
the challenges that go with landing a
rover on mars
plus the challenges of covid and um
and just an amazing accomplishment and
what does this mean for nasa and its
future plans
so for robotic exploration you know
every time we
um execute a mission with new
instruments we
discover new things and things we never
thought we would discover so
that's that always informs our future
robotic missions
uh both landers rovers and orbiters um
this mission also has technology on it
one of the cool things is the ingenuity
helicopter
um it's a it's an experiment on this
mission
but if it's successful we can use it as
an observation science observation
platform by putting instruments on it
and also use it as a scout for future
rover missions
and uh and then just the entry setting
landing
capability it'll allow us to land
more and more larger more ambitious
robots on the surface of mars and then
for human exploration um we have
the medley mars interested in landing
instrumentation which is going to give
us edl information
um we have the mars environmental
dynamics analyzer
it's going to give us properties size
and properties of dust particles because
when
we send people we're going to have to
deal with that dust
and uh just it's just this is just an
incredible mission because of the
science and the technology
and caching samples from our sample
return mission
that will be an amazing mission the
first round trip
to mars and back and bringing those
samples cached by perseverance back to
earth to
examine with state-of-the-art equipment
in our laboratories here on earth
we have so much to look forward to and
we also have a student question coming
in from landon
let's take a look hi
my name is lyndon applegate i'm in sixth
grade and i'm
going to academy for academic excellence
and my question is
do you think we could get resources from
mars to help on future missions
or even as like a launching point
great question land and actually we have
an experiment called
the mox the mars oxygen in situ resource
utilization experiment or
moxie and it's going to demonstrate
generating
oxygen from atmospheric co2
and that could help gener you know
generate breathable oxygen and even if
we can liquefy it
oxidizer for propulsion systems so
that's a tech demo on perseverance
and then we're going to continue to
characterize the frozen water on
and below the surface of mars
and eventually try to figure out how to
extract that water from the martian soil
or we call regolith
and then we can use that for potable
water and also break it down into oxygen
and hydrogen
for rocket fuel so absolutely we're
going to try to eventually
figure out how to live off the land to
support human missions to mars
thanks for taking the time to talk to us
today steve thank you
and now that perseverance has safely
touched down on mars let's learn more
about what's in store for the rover
joining us now is surface mission
manager
jessica samuels jessica your surface
operations team has now
taken over what are they doing now yes
hi raquel we are so excited here
in the service mission support area
uh the team will do a handover with the
entry descent landing team and
pass any critical information and then
this team behind
us will be the team that does the health
and safety assessments
daily as we progress on this mission and
what do the upcoming weeks look like for
your team
so as we enter mars time now uh
the commanding team will be working
overnight while the rover is asleep
so that uh we can perform the initial
checkouts of our key rover functions and
our science instruments
and we have to do this all in time for
the regularly scheduled communication
pass which happens in the morning and so
we will be working around the clock
making sure that perseverance is healthy
and we will begin this exciting
adventure
and can you tell me what's it like
living on
mars time it's uh it's a little bit like
constantly uh
you know flying and changing your time
zone uh the rover
um you know on earth the rover wakes up
at the same time every day but on earth
that's 40 minutes later
so the team is going to be shifting our
work schedule by 40 minutes as we come
into work over the next few weeks
so it'll be uh it'll be exciting and
uh and some uh some late late nights
but uh but we're also excited and uh we
can't wait
it's a whole new lifestyle yes we also
have a
student question for you this is
sophia's video
hi my name is sophia lopez and my
question for nasa is
how's perseverance going to survive and
here's a
sign that i made from perseverance
thinking about earth
thank you well sophia perseverance
survives
um with a power source um that charges
its batteries
uh overnight while it sleeps and it
keeps heaters
uh on so that all of our critical
electronics can stay warm
as well as our mechanism but it's really
survived by the team
that performs the health and safety
assessments every day
and communicates with the rover and make
sure that
uh she's she's doing okay
well thanks for your time jessica and
good luck living on mars time thank you
should be fun let's head back to marina
as she gives us a sneak peek into the
future at jpl
thanks so much raquel it's definitely
bustling behind me
is not quiet like it was just 20 minutes
ago and congrats to the whole team
what an amazing accomplishment mike
watkins is the director of nasa's
jet propulsion laboratory he was the
mission manager during the curiosity
rover landing on mars
welcome mike oh thanks glad to be here
you can see all my mask markings
well you were just celebrating and
rightly so now you've been around for a
number of mars landings what makes this
one special
well you know two things i mean it's the
biggest and best rover we've ever sent
to mars
um and it can really you know do amazing
things in terms of you know its own
scientific exploration of this
habitable environment you know at
jezreel but you know it's also as as
as you've heard today you know it's the
first step in march tampa return so
really you know it's it's not only doing
its own mission it's setting us up for a
series of missions and to bring those
samples back
and you know a lot of the effort to
develop the rover was specifically
designed you know for that sampling and
caching system it's one of the most
complex robotic systems ever made
and you know having it down safely means
mars sample return continues
right on course and and and we are
moving forward
wonderful now jpl has a long history
with robotic space exploration
why do you think it's so important to
continue to push those boundaries
you know there's a lot of reasons i mean
obviously you know for for places that
are
far away like mars and even farther away
uh you know like europa
right now robots are the robotic
expressions the only way we can
make those scientific discoveries and
really understand these early
uh habitable environments in the case of
europa maybe it's even still habitable
and you know we're not ready to to go
there with astronauts yet
but the robots are ready to go there and
so we always uh you know our forerunners
and pathfinders
uh of of human exploration and we start
by sending
you know our eyes and and arms there in
the form of a robot
and uh it is just fantastic to be able
to do that and to learn from each rover
learn from the science and the
engineering and make the next one better
and make more and more discoveries and
every time we do one of these missions
we make fabulous discoveries and and you
know each one is